bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs alors ce soir stéphane le
borgne n'est pas là puisqu'il est en
espagne pour s'occuper des filiales
espagnoles et oui puisque diagonale ça
devient international et nous sommes
donc ici ce soir plusieurs puisque nous
avons un invité d'honneur en invités
qu'on aime bien diagonale il s'agit du
jeune grand maître international
français laurent frayssinet alors bon
soir laurent mort soir il va alors tu y
es tu reviens de la vitre opaque up déjà
pour ton actualité personnelle où tu as
fait le score de 7 sur vite voilà tout à
fait très impressionnant en anglais donc
très bon je suis je suis assez content
de mon résultat évidemment
et donc même de la manière dont ça s'est
passé j'ai plutôt bien joué dans
l'ensemble plutôt des jeux dans ce
tournoi donc je fais une performance à
plus de 1700 quand elle où j'ai fait une
performance à 2767 point l'eau donc ce
qui m'était jamais jamais arrivé donc
c'est vrai que ça me donne un bon
résultat et donc quelques points elo
gagné 2007 167 points l'eau c'est le
classement des tout meilleurs joueurs du
monde et ça tombe bien puisque nous
commentons donc aujourd'hui le champion
du monde fis des d'échec troisième tour
avec déjà des résultats intéressants
notamment donc il nous restait un
français enfin deux français en lice
après deux tours il s'agissait d'igor
nataf et de vladislav tkachiev et bien
nous en avons perdu au passage puisque
igor nataf s'est imposé malheureusement
dans son match contre la surprise du
tournoi rafael nadal qui avait déjà
sorti joël lautier
alors laurent tu as joué avec igor aux
olympiades donc tu l'as vu récemment il
avait fait un mauvais résultat là bas il
est et il avait très bien démarré ce
championnat du monde donc
comment est ce que tu vois cette
élimination tout à fait il avait il
avait très mal joué aux olympiades et
c'est vrai que là il avait fait deux
très bons matchs de fantastique match vu
que short avec la manette et le candidat
de kasparov en 93 pour le titre de
champion du monde donc c'est quand même
une référence dans le milieu chacun et
donc c'est vrai que cette élimination
moi je pense qu'il a été très fatigué
par son match grande chambre parce qu'il
faut voir qu'il jouait les il a joué des
partages donc il a joué quatre partisans
et des partages de croix oui rappelons
que ce championnat est très très
physique puisque le joueur enchaîne très
rapidement il ya deux parties donc ça
prend deux jours les parties de semi
rapide des tout de suite le lendemain on
rejoue voilà que lui jouait le lendemain
et donc c'est vrai qu'il a fait une
mauvaise partie mais mais ce qui paraît
enfin quand même à skis par elekta haut
à proposer nul dans cette partie et donc
league of pensant qu'il était mieux à
refuser pour essayer de gagner mais bon
c'était peut-être pas la meilleure
solution vu qu'ils devaient être fatigué
malgré l'euphorie d'avoir battu nigel
short donc igor refuse la nulle dans la
partie où les noirs ils avaient égalisé
semble-t-il assez facilement
ensuite il fait des erreurs et retombe
dans une finale mauvaises avec un point
de moins que la guitare aux transports
évidemment lighthouse a fait un très
très bon technicien donc pas facile et
dans la deuxième il n'a pas vraiment
saisi sa chance igor tout à fait ils
étaient ils étaient probablement moins
bien quand il fait nul mais je pense
quand même dans l'esprit du championnat
du monde ferniot leurs 25 ou même si on
est probablement perdant je pense pas
que ça soit trop d'un esprit et qu'il
faut jouer il faut jouer jusqu'au bout
faut tenter sa chance et et tant pis bon
si on perd ça ça fait quelques points
l'eau mais c'est vrai un pas important
par rapport à ce qui hier est ce qu'il
ya au bout du championnat nîmes en un
higuain en attaque donc éliminer notre
notre français a arrêté ici sa course
vers le titre de champion du monde mais
c'est pas grave puisqu'il en reste là il
reste vladislav tkachiev qui a enfin qui
est kazakh mais français d'adoption on
va dire le rond puisqu'il habite à
cannes il est sous le coup de france il
n'est pas encore il n'ya pas encore la
nationalité disons oui oui oui alors il
a battu le jeune nous des cases in china
fonds va revenir sur l'intégralité des
matches un peu plus tard donc quelques
remarques générales déjà qualification
de vannes en bas relief et topalov très
facilement sans les matchs des partages
et par contre il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup
match de ce qui implique beaucoup
d'égalité dans ce troisième tour il faut
voir que les joueurs en ont généralement
peur de l'un de l'autre et donc c'est
vrai que c'est pas étonnant de les voir
faire deux nuls rapide des relais dans
les parties longues et la jouer ans
miral pays d'où tout peut se passer et
ils se disent qu'ils ont certainement
plus de chances de jouer en semi rapide
et aussi sont certainement très fatigué
par ce rythme infernal de jouer chaque
jour un joueur très fort et d'être
obligé de gagner pour continuer là le
championnat
oui d'un autre côté c'est quand même
éprouvant pour les nerfs ces semi rapide
c'est à dire que l'on joue notre
qualification toujours un couperet qui
se joue sans trop de réflexion puisque
s'est départi de 25 minutes par joueur
c'est donc pas énorme
ensuite quinze minutes en cas de
nouvelle égalité ensuite des blitz donc
on peut jouer la qualification c'est
hier le titre de champion du monde
finalement sur un beat
oui tout à fait mais ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que par exemple quand on voit le
match 4 chefs qu'elle estime jane offre
il ya eu deux nuls en casque ou d'une
partie longue 100 km 2 jours pour se
reposer pour soit pareil sur ces semi
rapide donc c'est mieux que de donner
ses imaginons qu'ils se donnent deux
jours à fond dans les parties et qui
fasse quand même nul ça serait vraiment
ça serait terrible a déjà même celui qui
viennent ce tour-là a pratiquement
aucune chance de gagner le tournoi prévu
qu'il sera complètement fatigués face un
joueur qui par exemple a fait un ennemi
0 et demi en gagner avec les blancs et
en assurant et baignoire il n'y a eu
aucune chance
d'après toi faire deux nuls dans les
parties longues pour jouer en semi
rapides c'est une sorte de gestion
tournoi voilà tout à fait c'est les
joueurs qui se sentent fort en semi
rapides évidemment et qui est qui qui
ont l'intention d'un éloigne comme plat
19 4 chefs qui a de très bonnes chances
je pense que vladislav quatre chefs et
même s'il a eu des semi rapide difficile
et certainement meilleure forme que
d'autres joueurs c'est vrai que
vladislav tkachiev on le connaît mr
blitz de son surnom est bien il est très
très fort en se mérite il a donc battu
catherine geof qui lui également est
très fort donc il est passé et on
reviendra après sur les appareils mans
du quatrième tour qui vont être explosif
et très très chaud alors maintenant pour
continuer cette émission on va regarder
tous les matchs un à un donc premier
match évidemment le grand favori s'agit
de wisches manhattan anand qui jouait
contre
elle put ion le jour arménien alors
évidemment un autre gros favoris
évidemment c'est clair surtout avec les
blancs et je crois qu'il est bien mené
son match où il n'a fait nulle et noir
dans la première partie assez facilement
et avec les blancs il a une à fait comme
d'habitude il un peu des onglets et même
si elle soutient une bonne chance de
faire nul d'après lui et le problème
c'est que le soutien avec eux des
chances de faire nul non même s'il est
nul ce n'était pas dramatique pour un an
des dons qui c'est le genre de joueur à
nantes qui joue sans risque pendant
toute la partie et c'est vraiment
injouable et noir contre lui c'est un
supplice parce qu'on joue on joue toute
la partie on se défend tu dois parti
pour fair nul donc ces normes ans et
sait ce qui peut arriver de pire pour un
joueur d'échecs itunes a joué le jeu
contre un don dont j'ai jamais joué
contre un homme non d'accord donc pour
n'être tonnes qui n'a pas connu le
supplice à noter que vannes ont des vies
effectivement le rappelle à chaque
édition spéciale il est là bas chez lui
puisqu'il est indien et il joue en inde
donc il ya toujours systématiquement une
dizaine de caméras télés braqués sur lui
en permanence
il a une grosse pression
et apparemment ça lui pose pas problème
il gère bien pour l'instant il a gagné
ses deux matches facilement après anand
il y a le la surprise la grosse surprise
de ce championnat il s'agit de mmes
assiégea le polonais laurent tu as dis
toi même qu'il n'était pas très fort et
là il a remporté son match contre bdf
qui après avoir battu donc krasnenkov
déjà au 2e tour ce qui est pas mal oui
ce qu'est ce qui est c'est très très
très bien pour lien c'est c'est une très
bonne performance c'est vrai qu'il a des
idées un peu disons il un peu teigneux
quoi c'est un peu son style est un peu
teigneux et donc ils s'accrochent et il
a fait deux nuls dans une partie longue
dans les deux matches et après en semi
rapide des isbas il se bat jusqu'au
dernier pion et c'est dans ce type de
championnat c'est un style qui peut qui
peut aller loin
oui les battues speedman au premier tour
ce qui était déjà pas facile donc les
nerfs très solides et je crois que tu as
déjà joué contre lui et avait tu l'avais
battu voilà tout à fait
donc tu aurais pu peut-être à sa place à
ces chambres du manège en tout cas a
noté effectivement que sur une partie on
est capable de battre n'importe qui en
tout cas pour ce qui est de laurent
enfin il faut rappeler quand même qu'ils
aient le même classement un look may
well 2536 c'est la surprise de ce
tournoi
il est polonais et il s'agit de mmes
assiégea ensuite nous arrivons un match
phare le match
kalif man l'écossé était ce vraiment ce
qu'on attendait le match explosif de ce
troisième tour avec un résultat tout à
fait fabuleux alors on va déjà rappelé
un peu l'histoire de ce match c'est à
dire que les deux joueurs se sont
rencontrés à budapest en janvier donc
2000 il ya de cela 11 mois et peter
l'écho nom kalpen venait d'être champion
du monde
tout simplement puisque c'est le
champion du monde sortant peter l'écossé
est un jeune hongrois qui a 22 ou 23 ans
et qui est 5e mondial au classement elo
et peter et qu'on l'avait emporté quatre
et demi un ennemi c'est à dire 3,03 bien
avec les blancs et 3 nuls avec les noirs
ensuite ils s'étaient rencontrés
quelques semaines avait appris sa
revanche ali au tournoi de linares et là
ils se rencontrent donc élimination
directe match très très chaud lors on
s'était aussi rencontré aux olympienne
et l'écho avec les blancs avaient gagné
et il fallait voir la tête de qualif man
qui est semblait qui semblait dire qu'il
avait marre marre de perdre contre comme
ce type là
donc c'est vrai que kalichman hamalawy a
dû bien s'appliquer et bien se préparer
comme l'écho a envoyé un voyant déjà le
tableau il a dû préparer son match
contre l'écossé vraiment c'est sa bête
noire
oui effectivement c'est l'abattement de
caveman d'ailleurs si vous voulez revoir
ce match quel imman déco vous pouvez
aller dans les différents ghana l'on
n'était allé à budapest en janvier
dernier et on avait ramené un reportage
avec interviews de cali fans et de
pétards l'écho donc vous pouvez voir ça
dans les archives alors revenant
longuement sur les sur la sur la fameuse
flèche vous arriverez sur ce match
qu'est ce qui s'est passé deux nuls dans
les parties longues ça va khalifa ne
tient qu ensuite première série de
parties rapides de 25 minutes chacun
encore deux nuls vraiment les joueurs
sont solides encore une nouvelle série
de parties 15 minutes cette fois deux
nuls encore donc là vraiment il arrive à
se départager ils savent pas et savent
pas quoi faire
et là on arrive de rentrer dans les
beats mort subite c'est à dire les
blancs ont quatre minutes et les noirs 5
avec rajout de 10 secondes par coup ça
ça fait plutôt la rc1 les blancs en cinq
minutes non non non puisque en cas de
nul on continue à en cas de nul en
continu en tête durant continué à lancer
mort subite l'est pas tout à fait quand
même puisque six nuls on continue mais
des blancs partent avec un léger
handicap puisqu'ils sont quatre minutes
les noirs non 5 mais il en blanc ce qui
en disant les blanches et quand même un
avantage donc là nulle dans la première
on se demandait quand est-ce que ça
allait s'arrêter donc quelques nanas les
blancs dans la deuxième dans cette série
qui théoriquement peut continuer
indéfiniment et la superbe partie
d'alexander kalichman qui gagne donc qui
bat pitt haricots qui sort peter l'écho
de la course au titre alors est-ce que
c'est surprenant ce résultat je pense
que quand même oui c'est une surprise
parce que même si kelly cheval est
championne du mans on attendait les
collègues adecco a montré des résultats
ces derniers temps où il perd jamais
c'est ça mais c'est un peu c'est une
force mais c'est un peu il n'y a pas
souvent non plus mais donc c'est pas il
paraissait clair qui perd jamais ils
gagnent de temps en temps donc là c'est
un peu dangereux dans ce genre de match
où il peut faire deux nuls et l'élan
semi rapide mais c'est aussi une force
parce que quand on perd jamais dans un
match en général oui on ne perd pas le
match en match
tout à fait mais rami qui face à 40
il sert pas et donc il a pas péril a
gagné le match finalement oui donc
finalement on qualifiera guise image
qu'elle n'a pas perdu deux parties pour
l'instant il n'a pas perdu depuis le
début d'épreuve donc là c'est la partie
qu'on va vous montrer aujourd'hui enfin
c'est une des parties on va vous en
montrer plusieurs donc la partie là donc
la septième partie du match khalifa de
l'école voire même sinon je ne sais plus
bref la dernière partie du match quel
fan déco khalfallah les blancs donc on
va vous montrer cette partie tout de
suite voilà que quatre
donc c'est un blitz il ya cinq minutes
contre 4 c'est l'écho qu'il ya cinq
minutes a eu quatre ou cinq cavaliers f3
cavadee m6 c'est la petrov très à la
mode
tout à fait j'ai d'ailleurs je crois que
les coen avaient joué avant c'était un
peu le débat du match la défense petrov
avec les noirs les coins effet nul assez
facilement à chaque fois donc il
continue sur cette voie qu'elle prend
1,5
voilà des six câbles edf 3 quelle
épreuve 4 alors effectivement comme cet
indice les joueurs ont dû jouer
extrêmement vite
cette série de coups qui est très connue
des 4 des 5 1 toujours la lutte pour le
centre les pions qui se croisent donc
les blancs contrôlant les casots 5 et
les noirs qui contrôle peu de la caso 4
donc tout ça c'est très logique fou des
trois des six petit rock um medouar
labrie qui rockent maintenance et 4 on
attaque tout de suite le centre bell
tout à fait un essai de ils ont donné
les noms en avant-poste ans le 4 enfin
ans le cavalier un cadre donc faut
essayer de déstabiliser ce cavalier et
donc de s'attaquer à des cinq donc
l'année noire agissent par ces six très
logique pour l'instant on se demande un
peu où peut être davantage des bancs
dans la mesure où la pression semble à
peu près symétrique
voilà tout à fait en clis avait tout à
fait
d'ailleurs est ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur
c'est une variante sénatrice heures est
posée mais bon j'en sais rien c'est un
peu le point de la théorie moderne c'est
qu'on sait pas où et davantage si on
prend des 5 kg en prend des 5
donc pour l'instant tout est très calme
la tension n'est pas encore monté enfin
à noter qu'en regardant cette partie en
direct on va des frissons puisque il y
en a qui aiment bien khalifa n'y en a
qu'une dans l'écho et la faute peut
arriver à n'importe quel moment et la
partie peut se jouer vraiment très très
vite calé ses trois cahiers prend
cavaliers qui reprend bon normal fou g4
les noirs se rate aucune pièce tout à
fait pas de combinaisons pour l'instant
tour bien on met la tour en jeu donc ici
la tour crée une menace directe sur
l'option 17 et en même temps elle
envisage de temps en temps de passer par
les caisses des 5 mai pour les cultures
de 5
oui ce qu'ils payent des jours ce qui
est pas idiot qui est 17h je crois qu'il
ya un piège aux ronds il ya un piège
c'est à dire que les noirs donc assez
forte de tout à fait donc les blancs
peuvent le prendre
les blancs peuvent le prendre alors
d'ailleurs alors là je suis un peu une
question piège parce que je connais
cette variante
il faut jouer les psy validé 6-1 ferme
l'attend on en fait un atout réapprend
vient la ramasse et soit avec vous c'est
vite avec d'autres choses c'est assez
compliqué on peut prendre le pion mais
ça conduit en général à des positions
qui ne sont pas meilleures pour les
blancs donc on ne le fait plus après qui
a été sept le coup ont joué par
kalichman ch 3 pour elle 2 intermédiaire
on prend la paire de faux puisqu'ils oui
alors non parce que fois j'étais inquiet
alors effectivement sur
dans la position précédente on propose
au noir de jeu les fous pour un f3 dame
prend à ce moment là on aura pris la
paire de fou on attaque réelle option
dans des 5es et on aurait de bonnes
chances de taper un attentat fait avec
les deux fous donc h3 les noirs garde ce
fou et effectivement il peut revenir en
défense sur la 4g 6 faire une structure
blindés l'alexander kalichman attaque
avec tours b 5 une attaque latéral donc
attaque l'option des cinq caisses b6
c'est la défense ces 4 je crois que
c'est le coût qu'elles étaient plus ou
moins bien la mode dans la partie chez
rough kasparov caisse parents fuyant
castle of heroes casse parfait shirov
exactement fait moi je suis pas très au
courant de ces demandes que je diverge
un peu avant donc
disons que après après ces 4 l'idée
c'est que le fonds a le 5 est pas très
et donc ils vont être obligés de faire
l'essai ces clous et le pire les 5 et
cloud et donc forcément le four être
obligé de bouger ou alors le pion des
cinq ans va être père nu et en plus
c'est sa menace et 5 donc jouer ça veut
dire que on peut mais a priori pas
prononcé cas puisque le fourrage 500
reprises la menace des blancs c'est
d'avancer le plus encore une fois donc
il ferait donc une fourchette a
peut-être envie de cave et db6 époux des
six donc ça c'est le truc maintenant
pariente simple si les noirs avaient
joué dessus on prend pions puis on prend
pions je crois qu'on joue pour acheter
voilà rich aucoin
je suis même sûr pointe 7 après roy
prend on prend avec la tour et là on a
une très très belle attaque la mesure où
il n'y a plus aucune pièce à la défense
de roanne loire jeté entre 3,6 et matt
bientôt matt bientôt donc
on développe avec lg 5 manas tournage
suite mais la suite est donc des très
bonnes chances d'attac dans cette
position évidemment ce n'est pas
acceptable
sur ces 4 il ya une autre solution que
jupiter les coups qu est bien connu
c'est fou pour un f3 dame prend voilà
tout à fait c'est un sacrifice depuis un
an des blancs mais disons qu'ils à la
paire de fouilles à la tour qui joue il
ya la dame qui va jouer et je pense que
c'est en permission de manière forcée de
toute façon donc voilà donc c'est en
fait ce qu'on appelle un pseudo sa fille
ce document est pas vraiment sacrifice
puis on prend ces quatre effectivement
sur le coup on a perdu un pion
maintenant effectivement on va voir du
jeu fous ces deux tranquille donc on
voit les deux fous blanc qui sont
orientés vers le roi père le roi de
peter l'écho la tour blanche qui peut
revenir très vite soit son altesse g5
soit sur la case h5 avec gros est fait
et puis la dame blanche évidemment qui
est bien placé également d'amener cette
attaque la tour on va là t'as clatot en
défens b c'est donc un coup
multifonctionnel qui doute y est connu
par la théorie aussi il me semble que
j'ai déjà vu tout ça on est encore dans
la théorie à 2 à 4 voilà donc ça c'est
honteux qui défendent un tour et qui
plus tard peut-être menacera 5 et c'est
vrai quand on s'aperçoit que 6 à 5
lecavalier a pas tellement de 15 il en a
financé 8 sais pas mais
c'est pas très agréable d'accord donc
l'idée peut être de jouer à 5 est en
tout cas dans l'immédiat c'est de
défendre la descente tout à fait touray
fuite
alors maintenant faut 3 les blancs se
développe c'est un sacrifice de pions
vraiment à long terme un ska madness se
passer mais disons que tu en mets cette
saison n'a pas défendu
bien que les blancs menace de doubler
sur un collègue b et de jouer à 5 2
tours et a5 et ce serait le plan b c'est
tu vas être permis de toute façon
d'accord donc très délicat tour à des
huit tours fb un look noir est ce qu'on
peut reprocher quelque chose alors je
pense que pour l'instant ils ont mis de
retour au centre
la dame en 17 est pas si mal le front
des six non plus le québec risque et
quel est le défaut en fait de cette
position pour les noms mais le défaut
c'est surtout les avantages des blancs
clients la paire de fous et qu'ils ont
et qui vend sur certainement récupérer
le pur mais cette et donc plus aventure
- et si c'est vrai que si la tour 20 ans
mais cette c'est la septième traverse et
là ça va être terrible mais quand donc
les blancs en fait on a priori
suffisamment d'activités pour pouvoir
récupérer leurs pions avec donc les ce
qu'on appelle à les enterrer
voilà tout à fait fou c'est 7 donc c'est
pour ans mon avis c'est sûr à cinq
cavaliers bouge déjà le cavalier dans
des cinq maintenant oui important et
donc et tout reprend mais cette dame
sera plus attaquer donc tout ça a l'air
pas mal
donc l'idée de fos et sept c'est que ça
libère la dame et la tour vers la case
des 5 ce qui permet donc aux cavaliers
d'y aller tout à fait fou 4 khalid rien
ne va pas en pivot car il est très
méchant
à noter que secouer le couffo écarte
donc et pas mal puis le contrôle encore
une fois à cause des saints qui ça ta
fille a encore incluant les dom le plan
à quatre alors [ __ ] la corruption elle
et c'est là que ça commence
là ça commence à devenir extrêmement
chaud cette nouvelle tout à fait donc
rappelons que ces mots [ __ ]
quand même important blitz ça veut dire
que cinq minutes contre 4 va très vite
tourner 5 voilà atteindrait dame je
pense que la menace surtout reprendre 17
il devait y avoir quelque chose comme
cavalli c3 est donc dans cette position
tour pro b cette sas est une variante
qui n'a pas été jouée lors fois ci tu
proposes qui s est roi et où tour pointe
4 c'est l'hallali des tons pour garde
ton calme et à la 1ère fois mal donc ça
c'est un service de qualité à part mon
pasteur de ma raquette maintenant fait
quelques essais 17 points d'accord donc
attaque et la dame et la tour et puis à
priori donc on va une fois qu'on aura
repris là on aura toujours un point de
plus voilà maintenant le x 1 3 fait
grise mine
c'est dire qu'en fait on a réussi à
changer des pièces un peu atténué la
tacc est un pion de plus en finale je
ressens je ne sais pas si on va gagner
mais donc pour combler cette en fait
c'est encore un petit piège option mais
ça ne peut toujours pas et je penserai à
mon avis kalichman avait dû avoir cette
position avant celle du bien il devait
ce que je vais céder coup c'est
écologique des noirs et des blancs
enfin surtout des noirs donc c'est pas
très dur à prévoir pour les blancs et un
joueur de ce niveau en général va assez
loin dans les variantes et quand c'est
d'écologique comme ça mon avis là tout y
est déjà tout premier donc quand tu dis
qu'il a déjà tout prévu c'est à dire que
la préparation il analysé les raisons il
a regardé son pays il a pensé que
c'était mieux pour les blancs d'accord
donc tour des cinq attaques la dame
parce que peter déco lui aussi analyser
comment probablement fou désir c'est je
pense que les des coudes et blanc c'est
un peu plus compliqué que les ceux des
noirs 1,4 mb un fou et 4 mois même si
c'est pas très sains pour l'instant
positionnement on peut quand même dire
que les noirs ont l'air complètement
gagnant puisque ils ont trois millions
de places est lié donc ça veut dire que
dès que dès qu'ils peuvent souffler les
avancées c'est terminé mais pratiquement
dix ans qui sont gagnants mais
maintenant c'est un jeu dynamique la
part des blancs tempête il fallait n'a
mis que c'est rapide et lent voilà oui
en gros donc donc c'est davantage sur le
long terme des noirs sont indéniables
mais c'est vrai que le petit rôle que l
on s'aperçoit qu'il fn et qui va
sûrement être attaqué donc le petit rue
des noirs alors pourquoi le petit rocher
faible on l'a déjà dit en fait dans la
dernière émission de déco nanou t'étais
pas là laurent dès que le cavalier m6
est parti dès qu'il n'est plus là et
bien il ya toujours des attaques sur le
côté rock donc là tout simplement il a
oublié ses galons qui allait de fouilles
alain tourre et la dame avant cela
commence à faire beaucoup un bon
potentiel d'attac donc il faut attaquer
le roi c'est le sait le mot clé de cette
partie à l'attack tourage cinq attaques
le pion à vii donc et le fouet la tour 1
ça fait deux voilà j'ai 6 et à peu près
force et nous il y avait eu six aussi je
sais pas c'était fou voyant h6 peut-être
alors si c'est une variante bon c'est
possible ça n'a pas été jouée h6 ont peu
joué les tours en essais ramène la
deuxième tour et puis il est vrai qu
avec cette dernière
voilà donc ça c'est effectivement c'est
un problème alors plus tôt reprendre et
7 et si le four vient il ya un fossé si
ce qu'il y ait une ouïe
il commence à y avoir énormément
problème donc là il faut jouer g6 à la
place de schiste pourquoi parce que sa
contre attaque sur la tourache tiens
voilà tout a noté qu on sent déjà qui
commence à y avoir des problèmes
oui on sent que la qualif matches pour
prouver cette voie là il a sorti toutes
ces pièces c'est super parce qu'il est
en fait dans cette position il tourne
des scènes tournage 5 pour les orages
79.4 qui est partout qui veut aller ans
et si c'était quelqu'un va lier la dame
et la tour donc il peut aller il peut il
peut faire très bien en plus mais c'est
quand même très large on pourrait mieux
en mythe d'un morceau je pense il a
étudié chez lui c'est quand même
dangereux de mettre en plus de les
signes sont en prison sait jamais ce qui
peut arriver donc envie que sais je
pense qu'il avait un regard mais oui
c'est vrai que ce genre de pression n'a
plus envie de les jouer avec les noirs
quand on connaît pas on les mesure où on
sait qu'il ya des bonnes chances qu'on
puisse défendre et ans
et puis c'est pas évident claude puisse
réussir son attaque a fait c'est pas
c'est pas clair pousser cette donc là
c'est fort c'est tout simplement
et maintenant kalichman donc à cet
ouvrage sans comprise il faut bien le
rappeler est la replace ont des seins
qui rejoint en fait l'organe la tour a
fait son travail est là elle a affaibli
les noirs voyez donc en plus maintenant
on peut s'apercevoir que le foot case
noire née des noirs qui pouvait défendre
avant les cases du rock à angers 7 ans
provenant les fuites par exemple la fda
et et déviances et 7 et donc ça ça peut
être très important parce qu'on peut
faire x 6 km 6 par exemple et c'est matt
fu chi cela même s'ils souhaitent tout à
fait alors ça c'est un thème le fouet la
dame a d'ailleurs été enlevés dans la
partie tour des cinq attaques la dam dom
s'est vite c'est logique
tourcoing tours voilà bon simplification
tour prompt et là maintenant et la cdc
leur fout des cinq banques en dessous
des 5 c'était pas de la qualif man est
un fou des cinq là c'est le thème sur
youtube cette voie là car le point il
faiblesse
donc c'est vraiment terrible car il ya
quatre maintenant par année car il ya
quatre mille chez picquier franchement
oui c'est le temps de sortir cette
partie et qui a veillé à quelques pas du
tout dans le jeu donc
donc on peut dire que les noirs jour in
casa - ça devient ces problématiques si
dans cette position alors est-ce qu'on
pouvait envisager des m17
je pense qu'on pouvait envisager d'amd
cette vue qu'au pire il ya il y apprend
à vii qui on pouvait prendre cette voie
et prendre c'est cette espèce d'arles
avec de plus dans la mesure où dans
cette question de le but pour les noirs
c'est de défendre le turf cette 11ème 17
et par bus heyer fossé 600 clients tout
de suite qui est oui voilà bien vue de
renforcer six attaques et la dame et le
cavalier donc ça s'est terminé
directement dans cette position ça ne va
pas fou des 5
il faut jouer tour 17 alors maintenant
surtout si ce qu'est ce qui se passe et
bien sûr foot c6 maintenant il ya
laurier est ici
tours 7 il ya toujours cette avec
l'idéal qu'on a une fois je devais la
faim qui fera une découverte
enfin il ya de la paperie kalichman a
joué très précis mais à partir de
maintenant je crois qu'il est en fait
tout est forcée jusqu'au gain donc tout
simplement il a joué et avait l'air
tellement tentant ça c'est vrai que
c'est sympa alors lapointe et évidemment
ça laisse le fou en prison clément
peuvent le prendre mais là il ya fou h6
la fuite avec un matt rapide c'est à
dire que la dame est de fous menace de
venir sur la 4g sept as et non un échec
et mat
tout à fait donc ya pas de défense n'y a
pas d'échec intermédiaire aérien c'est
tout simplement terminal systemat dans
quelques bouts donc voilà ça c'est une
première remarque après 2006 dans cette
position la menace fasciste elle est
quasiment enfin les très très dur
appareils peter l'écho a trouvé le
ku'damm débite mais après d'âpres en
dame
donc là si on prend du fou eh bien on va
perdre la tohu faut donc reprendre le
tour ses forces et comprend des 8 pouces
et 6 après long cou une longue série de
coups forcé et bien les blancs sorte en
attaquant elcamedia 4 et le fou c'est 7
tout à fait et donc ça gagnait ça y est
une pièce en fait tout simplement donc
l'api tard des coups à jouer encore
quelques coups fou b6 fou prend 1,4
maintenant vous prendrez 4 c'est une
pièce de plus fou prend tour prend pour
un pur détour points 7
cette position va s'arrêter là ça a été
transformée facilement par cali femmes
puisque effectivement on a tous fous
contre tours pions donc pas de problème
on va lentement aller chercher ce pion
ces quatre avants ramener endroits au
centre et c'est un gain technique est
facile donc bon alors les nerfs sont mis
à rude épreuve dans ce genre de match
parce que la partie peut se jouer sur
sur rien sur très peu de choses il
suffit de quelques malfaçons gaffes et
ses plus tard les cookies quel fils oui
mais c'est dans toutes les parties
pareil donc je crois que à ce haut
niveau il a joué plusieurs plusieurs
parties contre kasparov chronique et
tous les meilleurs donc je pense qu'ils
ont quand même l'habitude et pour eux
bon certes on a un peu plus important
que les autres mais c'est quand même un
ton moins
très important oui oui donc
très important effectivement beaucoup
plus important que les autres puisqu'il
ya quand même un titre de champion du
monde et beaucoup d'argent
est-ce que c'est beaucoup plus important
qu'un terrain comme linares où il ya
quatre ans je crains munich est un arm
pour la pour la voir c'est bath et le 7
un système coupe c'est un beau tournoi
un très beau tourner en tout cas donc
voilà donc peter l'écho éliminés c'est
une déception et en même temps quelques
semaines qualifier c'est une
satisfaction
ces deux joueurs qu'on aime bien donc
effectivement c'est dommage pour pour
peter l'écho en tout cas c'est bien pour
c'est dommage qu'on me paye ce match là
un peu plus tard avec plus de parti oui
alors attention au théâtre il reste plus
beaucoup de gars plus beaucoup de
joueurs
oui d'accord mais quand même calice
manele qu il ya le champion du monde et
l'écho qui est 5e joueur mondial on
aurait pu s qu'un et ce genre d'affiché
un peu plus tard à noter qu'ils étaient
dans un groupe extrêmement fort puisque
dans ce groupe il y avait les crocs
kalichman joël lautier
il y avait également igor nataf nigel
short site oaktree volkov saccef que des
exodes extrêmement fort je crois qu'il
ya que des défauts oui il est des
joueurs qui savent qu'ils savent bien
jouer qui sont moins fait la plupart
sont à remettre déjà et en plus en
général ils sont il y avait des paquets
moins fort comme je tiens à acheter
imprécises et ça c'était pas un pari
zone de cette façon quand on regarde la
liste des zones au on peut on s'aperçoit
que c'est il ya beaucoup de très bons
joueurs et que pour ce qu'il fait bon
chemin pour le championnat du monde faut
être fou est très fort c'est clair c'est
clair donc quelques pannes et passer
ensuite match suivant leitao contre
vigor nataf donc ça on l'a déjà dit dans
les titres de cette émission c'est igor
nataf qui avait éliminé j'allais me
trompe et j'allais dire qu'il était
qualifié mais en fait non et oui il est
sorti gorce et raphaël leitao le jeune
brésilien qui n'a que
22 ans et salons oui un peu plus d'être
très jeune très jeune très prometteur
vraiment extrêmement technique pour
l'instant il fait un sans-faute rafale
de l'hectare ou trois liens avec les
blancs trois nuls avec les noirs donc le
tournoi parfait quoi contrôle routier
camilla il a gagné les noirs et fait nul
à ghlin avons pu le signaler
petite correction du manque d'eau risque
importante donc oui non oui enfin en
tout cas en général il gagna première et
parce que contre l'hôte il avait gagné
la première règle est noir ils avaient
fait nul avec des blancs assez
facilement et donc il essaie de gagner
une des deux portes et c'est vrai qu'il
doit être assez frais pour la fébrilité
on a donc effectivement c'est un
avantage il n'a pas joué de semi rapide
donc il n'a pas été stressé encore pour
l'instant orphelinats ou alors après il
y avait le match belga le match bulgares
entre visites aux play-offs et kiril
georgiev l'ancien numéro 1 contre le
nouveau numéro 1 donc qui relie orgue a
fait beaucoup plus âgés et topalov c'est
une jeune star montante
il a 25 ans ou 26 je vois un an près je
ne sais pas exactement
donc c'est le favori qui l'emporté pièce
me topaloff le nouveau numéro un mondial
match sans bavure en numéro deux mondial
numéro un du lierre c'est vrai que quand
on a l'impression que ces joueurs là
sont vieux mais en fait parce qu'on voit
on a l'impression qu'on l'a vu il ya
cinq ans à linares
on l'a vu il ya cinq ans après c'est
vrai qu'ils sont quand même très vite
aller dans le top niveau et c'est vrai
qu'ils s'envoient en jeune pont pour
toutes les parties qu'on a vu de
qualification assez facile de
donc de topalov matches suivants griefs
contre vendredi vendredi c'est le jeune
hollandais dryef c'est le jeune russe
ils seront tous à ces jeunes quand même
mais c'est bon vendredi pas de chance il
a perdu la première partie avec les
pièces blanches
oui mais c'est hier que 20 pays et joue
tout c'est parti à fond et qui l'est
c'est pas énorme quoi c'est pas la
sécurité n'est donc qu'en tire et blanc
il peut perdre
mélangez canard dont le voit pas souvent
fait remarquer - vendredi extrêmement
bien préparé l'ouverture j'ai beaucoup
de variantes à caractère forcé et je
profitais une petite anecdote avec lui
aux olympiades
donc j'avais joué ma partie contre jean
paul garde qu on avait regardé la
diagonale et est donc j'avais perdu à la
suite d'une préparation on est en ayant
une heure d'avancé ça lui arrive ça lui
arrive régulièrement sa prépa et donc il
est venu voir et en me disant i'm like
your style j'aime ton style donc voilà
donc c'était assez mention coussin pas
trop ferrailleurs nominalement
donc en fait c'est ça ce qui veut dire
c'est que donc logique vous devez lit et
très habitué à faire des très longue
préparation c'est qu'il travaille à
l'avance chez lui ensuite il déroute ou
tempo ça passe ou ça casse et
effectivement quand il est réfutée par
un joueur qui réfléchit dans l'échiquier
bien il a l'air un peu ridicules
puisqu'elle arrive et il a réfléchi cinq
minutes son adversaire a fléchi une
heure et demie et c'est lui qui a perdu
ce qui était arrivé contre lui a dit
prêt à céder
donc là il a perdu la première avec les
blancs et dans la deuxième il n'a pas
réussi à revenir fcc la c1 l'an donc
quand ils allaient quand il a eu les
blancs il s'est pas mal l'énigme on ne
force pas là c'est noël voilà on ne
force pas la série en tout cas vendredi
ne l'a pas forcé il faut le dire
ensuite alors il ya eu un extrêmement
beau match c'est c'est exceptionnel ce
qui s'est passé dans ce match et suite
l'air donc le jeune russe surtout jones
est en panne quant aux peignes le
chinois donc qui n'est pas john kyl et
enfin j'arrêtais très exceptionnel donc
suis donné un grand favori grand favori
de ce tournoi il avait gagné à bien
cette année donc on peut le revoir de ce
match évidemment dans les archives de
diagonale qu'on fabrique dans ce match
oui merci
dans cette correction et suit des
repères la première partie avec les
pièces noir se fait tout simplement
utiliser il a permis la première et oui
il est tout à fait il a perdu la
première en fait je sais pas j'ai pas eu
l'impression mais disons qu'il s'est
fait plein guinée un peu comme tous les
toutous les tous les chinois il a le
style un peu rampant et donc il a bien
réussi à vie c'était une écossaise où
très vite s'il a été affaibli une
mauvaise structure de pions et ensuite
peng a transformé son final de cavaliers
dont qui commence car il est revenu une
dernière mais bon il y avait leur nul
effectivement donc quand c'est pas clair
en tout cas après la première partie
civile et a mené au score et dans la
deuxième alors il nous a fait un feu
d'artifice on va vous la montrer mais
alors vraiment en trois quatre minutes
cette partie cette deuxième partie vous
suit les revenus avant de gagner les
semi rapide donc il était obligé de
gagner
voilà donc on va on va très rapidement
montré cela parce que c'est un moment
très fort de ce championnat
e4 e5 kalyev 3 qui sait si ce donc là on
va très vite infondées 5 c'est une
espagnole à 6 x 4
quelque 600 hommes fawcett
tout ça c'est très très très connu un de
l'entente du hasch trois tours 8
des quatre grandes variantes justice on
va arriver à des moments où enfin
l'espagnol c'est très très longue
laurent comme comme ouverture on lui
tout à fait c'est les joueurs se lassent
leur piège à lacet
l'enjeu de manoeuvre manoeuvrant lemieux
va gagner à partie alors ici à noter
quand même qu'il ya une blague qui a
circulé parmi quelques joueurs d'échecs
c'est que pong est un gros spécialistes
de la stand yens et qu'il arrive à jouer
est indienne même contre le cou aux
quatre serres classées commencé comme
une espagnole et maintenant on reconnaît
toutes les caractéristiques de la star
indienne ses terres les blancs le centre
et les doigts ont mis leur fout en fait
un cadeau donc ça ressemble un peu
donner l'armée canadienne ken problème
dans le foot blanc elle fait deux fois
mieux alors là laurent je crois que tu
fait fausse route
mais effectivement en tout cas ça avait
l'air plutôt prometteur pour les noirs
c6 b4 surprend des cinq pions prend dé
5,5 qui est b3 et petites combinaisons
enfin qui est extrêmement depuis qu'elle
ya 5 ans et 8 mai 3 et là ça y est bon
évidemment les noirs c'est l'heure de la
tacc g5
alors l'idée ça peut être de ramener le
kényan juger si ça peut être
éventuellement de jouer le coup et cinq
beaucoup d'idées qui est de 10 h 2 à
noter que le camion avec 4 est
indélogeable puisque dès qu'on touche et
3 le curage 3 sera en crise key ces six
attaques la dame donc évidemment c'est
une invitation c'est un sale fils de
[ __ ] après france et six pions prend
tout reprend les noirs gagnera un pion
mais ils me cassent blanche
le fauve et 3 se réveillerait mai puis
la dame blanche aussi et puis la
tour-blanche arriverait donc ça va pas
un ghetto qu'alliance et 6 super garde
le j'en veux pas kg quatre attaques la
dame faut la prendre
ouais tout à fait convaincu non
maintenant on peut voir que quand même
là la bataille du côté de la halle dame
est gagné par l'exemple peu après par
exemple à quatre et ils vont gagner un
des deux pions ci qui a pu en point cas
depuis ainsi s'être perdus et si à
papillons pour 1 4 le pion bessanais va
être perdus dont les blancs ont gagné du
côté de la halle dames c'est clair donc
faut que les noirs
contre attaque du côté des landes donc
qu'avec des cats effet double attaque
sont plongés 2 avec les deux cavaliers
et il ya une photo ne pas faire leur ont
siégé trois ans voilà qui aurait été
possible mais qui perdait donc après le
cafouillage 3 puisque maintenant il ya
la dame et que viège 3 échec un échec au
roi le pion à f2 va être prises
bref une catastrophe tout s'écroule et
s'est terminée très très vite
donc ça c'est un petit piège donc après
que le h4 et noir gagne un pion
puisqu'on peut pas défendre le pion un
g2 donc tour 3 beaumont pitcher deux
tours j'ai trois cavaliers h4 alors on
peut se demander pourquoi spider à
monter c'est tout ranger 3 et bien
maintenant on s'aperçoit en fait que les
dockers virage 4 4 sont emmêlés tout
seul tout simplement il ya plus d
attaques du tout pour les noirs il peut
plus ils peuvent plus rien rapatriés du
tout et ça va être donc la taca les
dames c'est à dire les attaques de
l'autre côté un côté droit de
l'échiquier côté gauche sur l'échiquier
avec à 4 qui arrive d'ailleurs ça arrive
tout de suite à 4 mg si cela les noirs
ne savent plus comment attaquer donc
pour l'instant spyder une un beau
sacrifice d'options on va dire tout à
fait fausses et de six
h c'est un couple à l'attaqué oui et
c'est l'attaqué et c'est d'attaquer mais
plus précisément tour b sat pour un
shérif tour 17 avril à un plan là il a
ramené sa tour comme ça il a privé
s'inquiète maintenant il veut aller
prendre le pion des six nouvelles cibles
pions projet cadre d'un projet quatre
dames h7 alors là ça y est la batterie
est installé donc et beaucoup de
retournements de situation dans cette
partie c'est ça qui est assez agréable
c'est ozil et blanc sont gagnants après
on se dit ah tiens finalement il ya deux
cavaliers plus à une batterie dame tour
on voit ici il va se faire mater en fait
non celui de la retenue 3 afin qu'elles
aient gêné le roi s'en va avec tout à
fait pour prendre ici là-bas il n'y a
pas de y'a pas d'attaquants fait d'un
machin échec tour julien et là y'a plus
rien tout simplement peng joue damas
trois échanges les dames
en fait ils avaient très très froid
c'est tout simplement la catastrophe
c'est à dire quand on a une position
d'attac et qu'on n'arrive pas à conclure
eh bien ça ne se passe en général pas
bien a pas de match 3 de l'autre à
échanger les armes évidemment dame prend
et ensuite il a mené son pion d adam
donc c'est une transformation assez
basses avec la paire de fourrer incarne
plus ça devrait aller
et le cas malien sait si ça c'est
monstrueux il ya pas d y ait plus de
problème s'il ya ici a pas de maths et
vue qui a pu les dames
voilà c'est bon sens l'état n'y a pas de
match donc ici celui de l'air a gagné
cette partie ensuite il est revenu à la
semi rapide donc on peut se demander si
le meilleur moyen de gagner une partie
qu'elle est il tout simplement cantona
les pièces blanches et qu'on est obligé
de gagner
est ce que la méthode de si l'air est
vraiment la bonne de l'essai de jouer
quelque chose de tranquille deux balades
en l'état c'était assez tranquille on
dirait l'adage de plus en plus nerveux
et essayer de jouer sur un air visiter
son adversaire c'était pas mal surtout
pain est moins fort que génère donc
c'était un peu d'espoir et donc c'est
vrai que c'est pas mal à mon avis de
faire durer la partie de jeu assez
technique et 2
et comme ça on voit que d'un guy l'ajout
des remarques il n'est pas si mal joué
mais disons qu'il est il a montré sa
nervosité calme effectivement il a fini
par craquer très vite dans les parties
semi-rapides match suivant c'était le
match adams contredire rollins qui alors
adams on dire un métronome pour
l'instant il a joué deux matches à
chaque fois il a fait deux nuls dans les
parties longues mais à chaque fois 2 0
dans les semi rapide circuit où il joue
simplement lui pour le match à semi
rapide gir molines ski c'était un peu la
surprise américaine puisqu'il est
américain donc alexis obolensky
il avait remporté les deux premiers
matches tranquillement et là tout à fait
y jouer contre adams donc nm ce qui est
très fort en semi rapide mais moi je
sais de quoi je parle puisque je crois
que tu as joué contre adam se
rencontrent je crois aussi
donc oui j'avais perdu la première j'ai
fait et menaces bombe mais c'est vrai
qu'il est impressionnant il joue des
coûts naturel est bon très rapidement
donc c'est assez désagréable mais ce
qu'ils font en semi rapides quand on
veut des coups forts et en les jouant
vite si cécile quand même pour
l'adversaire c'est pas facile et donc ça
m'étonne pas du tout quand semi rapide
il surclasse ses adversaires
effectivement michael adams toujours
extrêmement fort extrêmement caténaires
ça c'est sûr c'est probablement le
joueur le plus décontracté le plus
relâchée du circuit et pourtant il est
bouillonnant il est vraiment neil
extrêmement impressionnant michael adams
tous les tournois élimination directe ad
réussissent très bien rappelé au fond
historique dans ces championnats du
monde
il avait été alors que je dise pas de
bêtises en finale la première édition
contre mais les chemins de table anand
deuxième édition il avait été éliminé en
demi-finale comptable akopian akopian
voilà donc une finale une demie finale
beaux scores impressionnants allemand de
verglas mais il ya quand même pas qu'il
a nommé à part attendre qu'il ait joué
qu'une fois et qui a été jusqu'en finale
donc adams toujours là ensuite il de la
partie morose et beach vladimirov
morozevich
c'est le grand favori numéro deux de ce
tournoi au classement et l'ofii des
ultras surprenant il a gagné des points
il est très jeune il est russe il est
extrêmement fort effectivement il fait
office de grand favori dans ce match
entre vladimirov contre la douleur mais
il confirme oui tout à fait une
d'où la différence n'est pas très connu
mais il a quand même de mes 6 ans donc
c'est un très bon joueur
ces îles et kazakh comme ladislav quatre
chefs et donc c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de talent je sais pas il
habille et je crois qu'il est bâti au
four joueurs on tourne avant il est
battu je m'en rappelle plus alors il a
battu barrois et
et c'est tout et almasy à l'asie voilà
donc il a battu l mazinghem asie qui
était quand même un des gros outsider il
a battu l masi donc ça prouve que quand
même c'est un très bon choix très très
bons joueurs donc là il était opposé à
mort the beach tête de série première
partie hilbert et deuxième partie
effectivement avec les pièces blanches
s'ils n'arrivent pas à revenir morose et
beach allant même jusqu'à sacrifier la
dame dans une position extrêmement
compliqué donc morose et vite je ne
s'est pas posé de questions oui il a une
lui suffisait il est un petit peu mieux
où il certifie la dame voilà mais disons
que le sacrifice dos d'âne je crois à
lui fort c'est une bien sûr et moins a
même vu qu'ils avaient sur certaines en
gagnant chance et donc je sais pas c'est
pas très clair c'est pas tout à fait
évident en tout cas moi on the beach est
passé le tenir en fait éliminer ensuite
on avait le match
ladislav quatre chefs contre kazim janos
donc ça on en a parlé
vladislav tkachiev le français
d'adoption il est quasi acquis mais il
est sur la liste elle ou française deux
nuls dans les parties rapides comme
disait laurence et de la gestion de
tournois en fin de nuit dans la partie
longue de journée de repos il joue en
partie rapide des premières séries et
bien vladislav avec les blancs fait nul
deuxième partie là les noirs il gagne
voilà enfin disons qu'avec oui c'est pas
très important en partie rapide et les
noirs c'est pas comme un parti là on a
beaucoup plus de chances de gagner vu
que c'est du jeu rapide et donc il ya
beaucoup plus d'erreurs donc leurs
avantages leurs avantages d'avoir le
trait est beaucoup moins important
partira quatrième donc il est passé tout
à fait ça c'est bien maintenant alors là
il ya vraiment la surprise alors j'étais
stupéfait encore une surprise y en a
beaucoup
s'écrie choo contre serveur serveur
c'est un fort grand maître russe qu'on
connaît depuis assez longtemps
eric choses qui m'a le plus surpris
c'est sa date de naissance puisque
laurent où il est né en 1983 ça veut
donc dire qu'il a 17 ans oui mais moi je
le savais depuis longtemps un macho
connaît malgré le choc je les ai vus
quand il jouait à moins de 10 ans donc
malgré tout que c'est vraiment pas je le
connais depuis j'ai l'impression nos
colonnes depuis que tu n'aies quoi donc
et puis j'ai toujours vu bien joué mais
bon c'est vrai j'ai joué plusieurs fois
conduit j'ai fait deux nuls une perte
et c'est vrai que j'ai c'est un très bon
joueur il a toujours été très sérieux et
il est considéré par les par les russes
comme le meilleur espoir de la nouvelle
génération et c'est vrai qu'il est
vraiment très fort et très
impressionnant mais il joue très détendu
et il joue assez vite donc ça veut dire
qu'il est sûr de lui donc je pense qu'il
peut aller et en plus il a un appareil
noir assez favorable au prochain tour
donc il peut il peut aller très loin je
pensais qu'il pouvait déjà passé
quelques temps cette année mais et qui
serait plus dangereux les prochaines
années mais là il est déjà très
dangereux et il peut battre peut battre
n'importe qui alors pour l'instant c'est
bien parti
on veut montrer parce qu'il a fait un
très très beau sacrifice contre ses
repères donc on va vous le montrer c'est
vraiment impressionnant
c'est une petite série de trois coups on
va y passer alors 1983 ça veut dire
qu'il a le même âge que bacrot et que
ponomariov tout à fait donc vraiment
alors que le pack rouault a été éliminé
pendant mario fossiles y uk le dernier
survivant des jeunes donc on va passer
tout de suite sur la vente de santé que
calcio que ba a battu ponomariov
plusieurs fois un score largement
positif quand points de maria of quantum
bacrot il n'a jamais joué
je pense ou d'un catégorie vraiment très
jeune et donc je pense que c'est
vraiment c'est on parle beaucoup de
points 20 fév accroc mais je crois que
j'ai vraiment très fort avec il est au
moins à mon avis au moins si fort que
quelques maquereaux et paula mariage
c'est possible en tout cas ici là il l'a
prouvé
puisqu'il est prouvé qu'ils étaient même
plus fort est d'attaquer à très
dangereux avec des blancs les derniers
coups le truc c'est de monter la tour en
trois serveurs amis les jouets d'un v6
peut-être un petit peu
légèrement alors maintenant il ya tout
rage 3 donc on voit la tour et la dame
la dame qui menacent de venir sur la
case h6 on voit qu'ils habitent toutes
ces pièces à l'attack le fou également
est présent le cavalier peut sauter sur
la case des 5
c'est pas mal il ya des belles
perspectives d' attaque donc là déjà
la menace c'est matt en quelques coups
donc il faut jouer enfin en tout cas a
été joué le coup h5 là on se dit ça
tient pas de problème au prochain coup
les deux mains peuvent retour à schwyz
pour renforcer la défense et à égalité
matérielle donc la partie est normal et
en fait pas du tout cela de tous que
jouer un coup vraiment inattendu ouais
enfin c'est qu'à mon cou quand on
regarde mais on a l'impression que ça
fait que nul n'a fait qu'un tour pour h5
donné le tour en réalité un seul a dit
au passage la menace des matches 6 le
cadeau doit être accepté si on prend h5
cadeau empoisonné d'alger cinq échecs
oui le cadeau grecque un rouage suite
d'un proche cinq échecs trancher vite un
roi 7 et donc se dit effectivement les
blancs vont faire nul avec dame g5 des
matchs 5 500 en gaz pendant que laurent
noir va rester sur ces deux là mais non
donc j'ai cinq échecs m'ont alors
effectivement on peut répéter quand même
et maintenant tourner ou une idée simple
et forte tour en trois tours h3c au
logement qui est bien c'est ramène
encore une pièce à l'attack qui touche
trois matches en fait voilà puisque ça
sera avec sur deux colonnes
donc ça c'est la menace à noter que si
les noirs autour g8 un peu
aventureusement damage six matches n'ont
pas tout à fait le baiser de la mort ça
aurait été dommage cette note annette
effectivement c'est pas pareil
voilà donc dans cette position qu'est-ce
qui aurait pu défendre aussi c'est
beaucoup d'âme ses 5 voilà mais ça
change rien même ses cinq chiens et
cible ont fait échec au roi j'invite et
tours 3
pour 3 ou et 5 5 un peu embrouillé
menaces fois statuts et du mat qui est
totalement apparemment c'est à dire que
le foot se réveille dans cette position
et c'est fini donc voilà ça c'était les
deux coups de défense a priori évident
après tout rien pour éviter le passage
de la tour 101 5 pourquoi ça marche et
qu'aucun avant la demie 6 cl soit là
tous rangés vite c'est une question
qu'on peut se poser à la place de donc
de tournoi oui je ne sais pas je pense
que de toute l'avait vu peut-être le
coup f5
enfin là on va pas envoyer nos
internautes
déjà juste pour leur expliquer c'est que
c'est un sacrifice de destruction donc
vous avez vu on april et d'options
monast euros 3 et là il n'y a pas
d'autres défense que de jouer cavalier 5
et se résoudre un peu trop trois à jouer
d'un proto voilà donc tout simplement si
on gravit un à près de 33 et bien il ya
d'autres tournois de tous rangs
normalement c'est plus fort qu'une dame
et elle avec les deux pions ces voiliers
lui le roi le roi qui est très faible
c'est c'est le cauchemar un point noir
et il avait il a perdu sans surprise
donc on revoit les images au ralenti
tour h 3 h 5
hélas le sacrifice de destruction tout
repos h5 la pression prend d'alger cinq
échecs et ensuite la suite on la connaît
on ramène l'auto en jeu d'un cran h5
roger cette dame g5 et chaque rouage
huit tours 20 et s'est terminée plus de
défense donc voilà belle victoire de
groupe dans un beau style d'attaqué
effectivement leurs joueurs donc il est
extrêmement probable il a l'air très
solide avec baignoire et
et très agressif avec des blancs ce qui
peut ce qui est dangereux d'accord parce
qu'il peut perdre règle et blanc mais
bon quand ça marche avec des blancs
c'est tout bon toubon élevé ce tome
obsession c'est le match suivant elle
reste très très chaud en semi rapide
puisque après avant le show qui est bien
il bat nos obsessions facile voilà en
lui c'est vraiment lui quand il vint
choo qu'il a souffert la première partie
avec les noirs et avec les blancs ils
avaient fait nul en 5 ou je m'appelle
donc ça veut dire que lui il joue
vraiment les semi rapide il est là pour
venir en semi rapides à noter que valve
est donc tu m'as dit laurent aux
olympiades avait tendance à voir
beaucoup surtout faire bises et poignées
surtout vers la fin c'est à dire c'est
un joueur qui est l'alcool facile et
mais là bon pro champion du monde eh
bien il fait un effort
je pense que elle va très peu connu mais
en pleine forme il vient de passer
mauvais escient et donc il est au
troisième tour qualifiés bas relief
contrôle alexandrov facile barrière
s'est qualifié mon à noter que c'est un
joueur pas très connue en face
alexandrov donc deux victoires direct en
partant d'un gamin quand on gagne la
première si l'autre et sportif
c'est absolument gagner la deuxième et
s'il n'a pas la position pour gagner un
deuxième et voilà rien eh oui ghoul coup
le vétéran du tournoi il a 53 ans
maintenant dont il dénonce 53 que le
dispatch nalyse c'était peut-être
d'ailleurs le match des deux vétérans
donc là une fois de plus la loi a été
prouvé quand on perd la première avec
les blancs et bien on revient pas dans
la deuxième goulemot facile il a
verrouillé après sa victoire avec les
noirs un fils il ya eu aucune chance
pour ce bac par julie rappelons ans un
second temps de kasparov games week est
très belle victoire de boris belle forme
dans la première avec une très belle
perception et dans la deuxième pic à
tavel et blanc mais n'a pas réussi n'a
pas trouvé le chemin pour revenir mais
que les fans très à l'image de ces bons
résultats dans les derniers temps noir
je pense que c'est un d un des favoris
de l'épreuve quelle forme qualifié
shirov gourévitch deux très bons joueurs
je sirote pour shirov extrêmement
dangereux puisqu'il est 4e mondial il ya
battu creigh indiquant match gourévitch
c'est l'ancien second temps de kasparov
il a été numéro trois mondial dans les
années 80 donc très bons joueurs
null null dans les parties longues
shirov gagne le premier semi rapides
gourévitch revient donc un partout et
ensuite chirouf gagne encore un mégot
avis je ne reviens pas on peut remarquer
que ce sont des jeux deux joueurs très
forts et gabin et c'est pas étonnant
qu'ils aient eu qui lui plusieurs
victoires chacun avec les blancs parce
que avec des blancs ils m'aident
vraiment la pression et celles qui sont
peut-être un peu plus faible à gay noir
donc nous avons fait le tour de tous ses
matchs maintenant quelques petites
statistiques pour avant de vous donner
les appariements les seuls joueurs qui
n'ont pas fait de semi rapides y en a
plus que 5 ha non de lake tahoe
morozevich égale fonde pour l'instant
ils font des sans faute c'est qu'ils
gagnent leurs matches il est pas la fnac
thulani topalov aussi oui topalov aussi
donc oui je les dis topalov nom de
l'acteur au total en france débute chez
belfond de cinq joueurs donc voilà sur
les seize survivants donc au troisième
tour il y en a cinq seulement qui sont
issus des qualifications
c'est à dire qu'il y en a onze qui sont
arrivés au deuxième tour puisque les
têtes de série arrivé au deuxième tour
donc on appose comme ça et 5 seulement
qui sont passés et ma siégea la grosse
surprise du tournoi
c'est le joueur qui a joué le plus de
parties puisque en comptant les semi
rapide aller vite il en est déjà à dix
huit parties je voulais le teigneux ce
qui est parfait
6 il fait 10 nuls et il en perd deux
donc ma siégea finalement il en veut
pour son aplomb joue beaucoup
maintenant on va passer aux a
pareillement du prochain tour ça va être
complètement explosif ce prochain tour
justement mme assiégea puisqu'on en
parle sera opposé à anand a priori
laurent pronostic je pense que l'alarmé
et à une grosse cote un bon gros favoris
et pauvre maxime jacquier joué 18
parties en plus doit pas être dans un
état de fraîcheur un extrême et donc ça
va être très dur pour nous donc pour toi
annoncé de toute la ds que c'est
favoriser preuve déjà en général je sais
pas mais disons que c'est oui c'est
probablement le feu devant une épreuve
mais en plus à domicile donc louis c'est
le favori hollande à domicile donc
contre mme assiégea ça va kalif man
alors là il a entre guillemets une
journée de repos puisque après les coups
joués lighthouse et comme une bonne
nouvelle tout à fait alors lighthouse
va-t-il continuer à nous surprendre
puisque france en est ressorti deux
français est-ce qu'il va sortir notre
chouchou chou diagonale donc alexander
quelques femmes pas su en tout cas
voilà le match khalifa de leitao topalov
dryef c'est un match super sonne ça va
être chaud derrière il va essayer de jeu
c'est parce qu'il a essayé de faire mais
ça va être dur pour lui à mon avis
topalov gros favoris ouais topalov grand
favori parce qu'ils rêvent à défendre et
s'il arrive à faire une petite
contrainte ac a placé une contre attaque
c'est comme en boxe mais qui se défend
toute la partie et après qui arrive à
placer un uppercut est sur la fin
peut-être qu'il peut gagner donc les
surprises sont possibles toute façon ces
deux excellents joueurs c'est clair le
plus beau match à venir évidemment ce
sera le match d'hier contre nataf contre
adam ce contrat donne décidément je
voyais coeur nataf partout mais
fidelaire contre adams contre michael
adams
ça va être superbe là c'est difficile de
donner un favori puisque tout peut
arriver dans ce match tout à fait tout
peut arriver donc espérons enfin on aime
bien adams en forme l'ambiance phildar
aussi toute façon c'est que des beaux
jours on les aime bien morose et vite je
contrôle quatre chefs
est-ce que de quatre chefs peut créer la
surprise ça va être très dur pour nous
alimenter bi tché
beaucoup à mon avis est plus fort mais
bon on verra peut-être on sait penser
pas dans les matches en deux parties
tout peut arriver toute façon mes
bonbons roses évite shekhem favori
riccio et lgv est donc la grille tout
qu'un gros fragment favoriser dans le
favori barailla beaucoup le cobaye est
favori puisque wilko est arrivé là a
larache et galfione shirov extrêmement
beau match ça va être probablement un
des plus intéressants avec sa manière
l'art et dams tout à fait les deux
matches phares qu'on suivra la semaine
prochaine dans des gones a beaucoup vous
donne rendez vous vendredi soir à 22h
pour le 4e tour merci de nous avoir
suivis